yeah it's this date the date fail it's
the date fails yeah so oh we're going
we're going hey guys what's up uh this
is Dave fails I'm Kate Quigley we are
back at Raleigh studios on all things
comedy and I'm very excited for my
guests I've been trying to get you
forever oh my god finally you're so busy
finally we matched on Raya and that's
how and that's how she finally got me on
the hook that isn't so funny though
we're both on this dating app that's for
what do you even they say it's you
listeners no like have you talked about
it ray uh yeah I thought what was funny
is I talked about it a little bit but
then it was like I thought it was like
Fight Club that you're not supposed to
talk about it or not like it's off right
I think it's cool I mean you're not
supposed to tell people who's on it you
know Dane Cook but you know it doesn't
it doesn't matter who cares you know
Dane Cook is on every dating app there
I've seen Dana tinder bumble D if you're
on tinder and you're Dane Cook like
that's crazy I feel like people wouldn't
think he's real he's like ah
some guys got a fake profile [ __ ]
around oh I thought that about Terrell
Owens when I match with him on tinder
you told me about that you guys actually
went on some tennis dates there were
really dates we hung out huh played
tennis um by the way let me introduce my
guys just before we go any further
you're first of all you're hilarious
your stand-up is so super funny your
podcast your podcast is so funny give a
plug to your podcast
oh the surely you're joking it's I'm
part of a co-hosted podcast with a
couple really smart scientists and we
interview legit NASA scientists and
comedians surely you're joking it's
great I love the podcast it was my
favorite podcast ever did I really so
much fun on it yeah yeah yeah and also
he's one of the stars of Silicon Valley
HBO which are about to start shooting
you said your fourth season warp season
crazy and you got a movie coming out
Patriots Day in December you know what I
think it's 17th and 19th nice yeah
that's so exciting I asked him who is
playing he said an Asian what he is an
Asian person you know it's based on real
people I can't just go play other people
know
yeah wait what's the movie about it's
about the Boston Marathon bombing it's
all you know based on a real event so
it's it's really serious and you know
it's not funny at all by any means for
you it's like a very dramatic dramatic
acting uh I've done some but this is
definitely like one of the main things
I've done and I'm very very just honored
to be part of this because it's such
like a sensitive subject yeah what
happened like three years ago yes yeah
very recent it's great the cast is
awesome
it's Wahlberg JK Simmons Michelle
Monaghan Kevin Bacon and John Goodman
like amazing people and I I'm just so
lucky that you know to be part of this
because the guy that was involved in
this incident you know I could relate to
his story and and and he just I'm just
glad that an Asian person was involved
in this incident that's why I'm in this
movie you know that's great Jimmy Jimmy
ou yang everyone you got to follow him
at funny asian dude uh but I love you
I'm so happy that I finally got you in
for this so yeah it's been what like
months yo and now me I'm sorry it's a my
Sonny you're working right exactly but I
mean it's just some people are always
ducking me he's not you know no but dude
you're so cool about it every time
you're always like I swear I want to do
it ask me again which is I could tell
when people are just like I don't like
iMessage one guy I won't say who I
messaged an acting book that I'm friends
with Dane Cook and uh and yeah and he
was like I this was months ago by the
way it's like three months ago I hit him
up is just like hey would you wanna do
my podcast sometime he was like I'm
shooting until January it was just
basically like and be like what is he
shooting then I get the next avatar I
nod that you definitely not shooting
that I don't think is gonna be the next
avatar so uh but yeah so you and I we
matched on Raya Raya I don't know I
think
riah talk about this cuz I haven't gone
much into detail about it a Jonathan
kite
oh [ __ ] oppression whatever he talked
Jonathan kite was on here uh months and
months ago price six months later guy
very funny guy and he was like I'm on
this dating app for uh quote
you know celebrities whatever I think
it's run by celebrities I heard Kelly
Osbourne is one of the like founders
about I'm out I cancel my membership I'm
out you have to be approved so yeah so
you have to have two references and be
approved I think when I got on I got on
like maybe a year ago or something um
and then I met my girlfriend right after
that not on riot but on you know on
tinder actually did you really yeah and
then we went out for eight months and
then we broke up so I got back on Raya
and then that's when I heard it's really
hard to get on but I was kind of
grandfathered in so you gotta be verify
there's like a panel of secret judges
who are these judges I want to know who
they alright and it's connected to your
Instagram so some of them are like
aren't like necessarily famous people
but now you have a lot of if they call
it influencers yeah but some of them are
when I can't figure it out like there's
guys on there I look at their Instagram
I'm like who is like what DJ's right for
guys oh my god it's literally all DJs
skaters occasionally I will come across
like a musician or an actor who I know
are but for the most part it's like 21
year old DJ's writers right they look
super douchey I I've looked at it from a
female perspective and from the guy's
perspective it's kind of the same it's
all girls what bikinis nothing against
you okay but it's like it's like iPhoto
just for the record is not in a bikini
on Riya but it's um it's like Instagram
models a lot of model pictures like
modeling pictures not headshots things
like that you know I mean yeah so it's
an interesting world have you got any
dates on there I have actually I've gone
out with three guys oh I've gone out
with three girls alright yeah discuss
okay the first one I went out with
actually I've talked about on this
so I call him um jewelry guy because I
lost jewelry in uh large jewelry in the
relationship
we went out he's an actor very
successful actor um went out so
successful you can't mention his name
time yeah I can't say a list yes okay
can't say who is Russell Crowe yeah
Russell Crowe um so no this dude we went
out for coffee on the first date we just
got coffee which actually he ordered my
coffee for me which was a turn-off
because he ordered me an almond milk
latte well I didn't want I know I get
annoyed when guys order for me that's so
Hollywood especially when you isn't that
so gross it's it's very like a
patriarchy patriarchy Oh paper
patriarchal patriot yeah there's just
like hey I'm the man I'm gonna order for
you I know and he was really nice and
stuff actually when I first met him but
cuz this guy has a reputation for being
a douche bag Oh Colin Farrell Colin
Farrell and so I just like went into but
but here's the thing I know because I
come off on social media as being like a
girl that like is easy and [ __ ] a lot
or like hyper sexual or whatever but I'm
not like that at all I'm really not so I
feel like I can see why people would get
you know I mean like a lot of bikini
pictures you dancing around is that why
that's yeah just oh and like I work on
the Playboy channel I host the AVN
Awards I'm friends with porn stars it's
just like people just assume things so
when I you know I didn't want to assume
the guy was a douche bag alright so I
tried to go into it with an open mind
but um we went out on one day and he
spent like 13 bucks and then the next
time I went to his place for a party so
he didn't spend anything and then the
third time I went to his place for a
party but then I ended up staying and we
ended up hooking up that night well but
so the joke is that your vagina is worth
however much guy spends on you before
you bang him that's a $13 well actually
then what happened is I wore like $30
worth of jewelry to his house from like
like forever 21 jewelry and I
accidentally left it there so I never
saw him again
after we hooked up did he subconsciously
do them purposely and hit him up again
got a lot of expensive jewelry for my
grandmother's house can I get it back
mr. Farrell
actually it's so funny because I sent
him a text it even said I know it always
seems like I left my [ __ ] there on
purpose to come get it but I really
didn't and I just want to come get it
back so I go can you just give it to
your assistant or something like yeah
and but I never saw him again so the
joke isn't that relationship my vagina
was actually worth like negative
negative 17 woven his fame whoever he is
you know is what nothing is that
something not really you know I was out
pay seven dollars to bang a famous
person see I have hooked up now with a
few quote famous people how is that like
is that like cool like they feel good
about it or is it just whatever I don't
feel any like more like cool because I
got them or anything like that because
the truth is I kind of get off on um
this is so horrible I kind of get off
unlike if I could treat regular guys the
way I treat famous guys they would all
be in love with me because I don't I
make the famous guys work harder usually
except for what this one way a guy he's
really hot very guy is he like a sex
symbol oh my guy he's not a quote sex
symbol okay just tell me off air I don't
I don't care about your audience I just
want to know yeah well he's not a sex
symbol but he is one of these guys that
like a lot of women he plays like an
[ __ ] a lot so a lot of me Piven oh my
god yeah Evan um so yeah he plays an
[ __ ] lot so a lot of women want to
bang him okay but but what I'm trying to
say is the guys I hooked up with to our
quote famous day and my experience are
not as good in bed as regular guys why
is that
I think cuz they didn't have to work as
hard I'd like they don't try they just
don't they don't care they're like oh
I'll just bang somebody else tomorrow
well but do you think they Bank so many
people they got to be pretty good at it
not at all huh cuz think about it like
if you hook up and you're just a regular
dude right you're gonna work really hard
could you want the girl to keep coming
back true these guys that's like they
know they can just go on Raya and hit up
another Instagram model
are oh you're so famous you're like
Terrell Owens I never hooked up with tio
but like if you're that kind of famous
I'm sure you can bang just about anybody
yeah maybe not him now cuz he's like you
know got nothing tio or the other guy
tio right yeah what about you tell me
about your raya dates that's terrible
it's all three Oh wha two of them no
actually I went out three times one of
them was horrific it was this girl um
she is a costume designer for some pop
star which I have a weakness for like
somebody that's not an actress not like
in the spotlight you know but in the
business but in the business and is
creative like an artist yeah I get it I
love it but she's from England so we're
just talking and you cuz you match with
everyone from Australia from England
from New York it's annoying yeah it's
actually annoying cuz everyone I match
with lived in like Great Britain or
Australia I feel like they're never here
but the thing I guess the point of them
doing that is we're on the entertainment
business we'll travel and we'll end up
at different places so um after this
girl you know I took her out she's in
she's first time America so she wanted
to like go to American bar took her
there she want to go to Dave & Buster's
took her there you know but the problem
was this girl she's like maybe early 30s
but she act like she's like a tween
because she runs like a tween
publication in Britain and it just like
so embarrassing the whole time she's
just like snapchatting like when we're
at Dave & Buster's
she's just like was snapchatting
non-stop and told me to snapchat her no
Mario Cart machine I was like come on
man bring your date she snapped yeah
yeah cuz she wanted look a how cool and
this guy took me out a merican date you
know to David Beckham Christ writes
David mustard and and she didn't look I
don't expect a woman to pay for anything
okay
but at least attempt to like you know be
like a no I got it like I'm not on my
dinner I'm drying so anything but like a
Dave & Buster's player's card wait a
second this is interesting to me because
I've literally had this same
conversation with other guys on here
where they're like I never know what to
do in that scenario cuz I used to always
go for the wallet like oh I'll guess but
they offer
but then a lot of guys are like look we
know it's when you go for the wallet
you're not really gonna pay so then it's
just like some guys are like insulted if
you try to pay like every guy is
different no no but if you reach for it
and that's your test for a guy too if
you reach for and the guy lets you pay
out that guy you know I mean but you
reach for it the guy is but don't worry
about it but I want to see that reach
sure or at least like I always try to do
something like I might not reach really
good to say what drinks let's say we're
at drinks we do drinks and the guy puts
his card down so like his card is there
right but then all gonna pay for parking
or tip the valet like I'll try to do
something exactly that's what like a
Dave & Buster's players card seriously
I'm it those things aren't cheap dude
they're not cheap and halfway through so
goddamn busy snapchat you lost a [ __ ]
card no yeah man I was like okay this is
over at this I almost walked out on the
date I didn't I just said I should go
are you serious that's pretty bad how
hot was she on a ten scale on a riah
scale or a tinder scale oh no I know the
right scale is like literally all the
girls are like models it's insane crazy
I've seen men never match with those
Instagram models I maybe I'm not like
cool enough I meant but I match with
like something like cool musicians or
something which that's nice yeah yeah I
met with some good musicians I met I
matched with this one musician girl uh
which I was a fan of she's not super
famous but she's like she had a
number-one hit like you know a couple
years ago but that was really cool and I
got to know her and it was awesome I
wouldn't hook up on anything yeah it
ended up I was on the road so much she
was on the road so much I only saw her
once but we text every now and then and
she's super cool sometimes that happens
on there I've met a few people in there
that we never actually went on a date
but we just started kind of like talking
or whatever and then eventually we met
by accidentally crossed paths at a party
yeah
that's pretty dope so you almost left
the girl that's so funny that was the
first time I was just so distraught I
I'm it made me evaluate my dating life
after that are you serious
I went through a phase where like I was
just going on because it's really easy
to get date on like maybe not riah but
like you know bumble tinder or what I
stopped using tinder but just apps yeah
easily and just set up like three four
days a week is it really because
I never do it it's easy for you you
could just like get your girl you
probably like mm matches yeah that's the
truth is I stopped trying to use the
apps because it's just exhaust it's like
a full-time job sorting through all of
it
absolutely that that's that's the main
thing like it's sorting through and then
messaging and keeping up with everything
yeah you know um and then sometimes if
people recognize me from the show like I
don't get stopped in a street or
anything like maybe once a week somebody
a good job yeah
but it's at a good level right but that
if somebody recognized me from the app
it becomes this really weird thing where
like I don't know if they want to just
hang out you know because they're a fan
of the show on a know more about the
show or they actually find me attractive
or something like that you know I mean
they bring it up do people bring it up
when you're just texting if some people
like to say first line is Silicon Valley
or whatever I can't talk to them like
they're just that's a bad start
yeah I know you can't I won't date
anyone like this if someone makes any
reference to my stand-up like I had a
guy the other day I imagine him on rheya
when I mattre someone on rheya I give
them my number right away because whoa
well because I only have Raya on my iPad
cuz it's not available for Android did
you know oh yeah you can't have it on
the Samsung though peasant phone I
always stop talking to you when you text
popped up green okay I love all right
I love the green candle how many of my
calls or texts well you could have made
so much more friends is that true yeah
that group text me oh I could it's not
as cool I'm green it's fine you know why
I love having a Samsung or any Android
phone because people don't know when
I've read their text it's so annoying I
can do that with Apple you can yeah read
receipts that's optional ah but the
bubble is not optional the bubble is uh
there the bubble the bubble as if when
you're texting yeah see I don't I don't
want that I don't want that I don't need
that I am I Lashley I think
subconsciously less inclined to text
people back that has a green bubble shut
up I'm serious why it's not I'm and I
don't think it pops on my computer
sometimes on my computer I'm texting
through my computer group text I can't
send you cool stickers you know a lot of
things man you
get with the times Hollywood it's all
it's all blue all right fine
maybe I'll get an iPhone okay but the
point is I gave I always give people my
number right away okay because I don't
care I'll just block them if they're
annoying right so this guy messages me
and his first message to me is uh so I
have one ball that's uneven too so we'll
probably get along because I do a bit on
stage about having like a lazy boob like
one boob that's like different from the
other so this guy the first thing he
says to me is that so immediately I know
that he like Google me and watched my
stand-up thing he googled he didn't like
watch you live somewhere and then so I
know yeah I think well he might have but
either way I don't like to date someone
that's already seen my act really no I
don't want I just feel like it's not
fair cuz you already know so much about
me I don't nothing about you and I don't
like that that's true that's a problem
with like a like celebrities and stuff
you can just google their name and know
everything about their childhood their
who their mother's name was like you
know I mean right it's really weird
that's why I never Google anyone I have
a rule about it but I think I need to
start because the last couple guys I've
dated I found out I've had girlfriends
or baby mamas or wives that's my that's
my thing I keep dating guys with
girlfriends you need to stop dating pro
athletes not just put well not just pro
athletes anybody yeah everybody has
somebody like right now how many girls
are you dating zero really yeah there's
no one there's no one I go on some dates
sometimes interesting yeah my daily life
is not very exciting I mean it's not
it's not that cool honestly it's not
it's I'm on TV right right and it kind
of helps in the sense that I can get
dates easier most people just want to
hang out you know like back in the day I
had a hard time maybe just finding a
date a week you know I mean or something
like that yeah
coz but but the people that were willing
to go on a date with me back in the day
you know they were kind of down with me
or you know I thought I was cute
whatever they were down with me for me
they were into you yeah now it's like
you don't know are they are they
actually do they just want to bang TJ
Miller and they want
talk to me you know I mean I wanna some
dates where like it was just weird like
she's kind of cool but like you know
she's not really into me she just want
to talk to me so it becomes like a weird
thing where I haven't figured it out and
I don't look I don't really go out that
much like these apps are [ __ ] perfect
for my lifestyle because I hate I don't
go out of clubs I don't hit a con 2 a.m.
you know yeah so unless it's like a
friend of a friend or something I don't
meet that many girls in in the
wilderness you know it's hard to meet
somebody out it really is but these apps
are kind of [ __ ] so it's it's it's not
that cool you know my problem with the
app is the small talk like I had a guy
the other day I don't like to message
back and forth a lot before we go out
let's say you imagine rheya yeah let's
say we really match right yeah no more
than like five text back and forth
before I will say I'll just go yo so do
you wanna like get a drink or something
I just don't want to waste time texting
back and forth a bunch with somebody if
we meet there's no chemistry I'm busy I
don't want to spend a bunch of time
texting well but aren't you too busy to
meet also like how many people can you
meet a week I just feel like it's easier
well here's my first date is always just
happy hour one drink an hour that's nice
I don't do like let's go to the beach
all day or like you know yeah so I'll go
why don't we meet for happy hour I have
a show that night I meet you I have one
drink with you I bounce and then if it's
good then I'll text with you more yeah
but I don't like to waste time I did the
other day message me and he was trying
to have a conversation he was it was
eight o'clock at night and he wrote
what's the most interesting thing that
happened to you today
we've never met and I didn't answer
because I was at a show yeah so then the
next day I got busy and I forgot to
reply and he sent me a text the next day
at 2 o'clock and he goes do you normally
give your number to guys you're not
interested in talking to yeah dudes get
like real defensive man it's really lame
immediately if you don't answer I don't
I don't get that I I never I mean
internet dating is very like the apps
you can't take any of that seriously you
really shouldn't
yeah I used to take it kind of seriously
but like now you realize whatever
there's another one around the corner
unless you eat until you guys meet
there's really it's just whatever it's
nothing there's not real yeah but I have
that it happen too and this is why I
also cut the small talk have you ever
had like I've had almost a whole
relationship with guys that we've never
hung out from texting because it starts
out texting like say they don't live
here
starts out texting then before you know
it it's like flirty texting maybe you
FaceTime you feel like you're kind of
spending time with them then you start
sexting then you start arguing what but
how come you guys never meet though like
a reason because they're not in this
state Oh like I did this with a guy who
lived on the East Coast and we kept
having the intention of getting together
at some point and then finally I
realized we were never going to get
together which is why I started getting
annoyed like are we ever going to really
meet up or is this just you're doing
this like cuz you're bored and then we
start fighting about it and then we
basically broke up and it was like we
never we never met in person there's
like a whole relationship yeah that yeah
I try to not let that happen
that's that could easily happen I feel
like yeah where's this catfish or not or
whatever right right it's just the
long-distance there's so many people
here in LA why do a why do a
long-distance I'll never do it again
never yeah it doesn't make sense like
for me I think I just keep going out of
town for like months at a time or a
month at a time it's hard to sustain
anything you're so busy it's it's well
now I'm back in town shooting Silicon
Valley so that's at least six months
I'll be in town yeah but after that who
knows you know and and then you know you
get some momentum going with a girl and
then you go away or like and then she
goes away actually it's hard to sustain
um so I'm surprised you've never met
anyone okay like there's gotta be extras
on your show that are trying to get with
you come on alright have you seen our
show yeah extra snow it's all nerds uh
that's true I was shooting this film in
Atlanta and there was a lot of hot
extras it was like a college movie okay
so a lot of really cute girls but the
thing is I don't want to look like a
dick just like going up you know I mean
like talking to an extra and that movie
was like mainly like a female cast yeah
so I look like a real scumbag yeah I try
to um actually I went out with one of
the girls stand-ins she was really cute
that's more reasonable yeah a stand-ins
different though because she's on set a
lot and Katara you feel like you've
taken advantage of her and you just look
like a dick I feel like when an extra
you got to tell the PA to be like hey
you know I think she's really cute which
is still a creepy move that's so creepy
but this just shows that you're a nice
guy because I've been on so many sets
where one of the stars of the show will
just like pull some extra you heard
about it all the time on like entourage
wait what right I'm not at that level I
can just bang an extra in my trailer you
think that but you probably could though
I I wouldn't want to bang that extra
that wanna bang me she's doing in my
trailer I mean come on man I'm like
number nine on the call sheet look at
the size of a port-a-potty I don't think
this is how it should go down dude where
are you from where'd you go up Hong Kong
really originally I didn't know the hut
yeah oh you didn't know when did you
move to the state's when I was 13 get
out we didn't talk about this on riah
yeah we did we didn't really talk much
on wrong okay but by the way what's the
rule of seeing somebody you know on riot
I always match with them on purpose just
because I feel like it's do you know how
many times people would message me and
gone hey I swiped right on you on bubala
and you didn't really i mostly swipe
left you do cuz like if you swipe left
and say your picture passes you swipe
right on me and it doesn't match it
doesn't mean that I didn't swipe right I
just mean and see it yet or something
exactly so yeah I know that yeah well
here's the thing if it's a friend like
you Matt right
I'll match with just cuz I oh [ __ ] I
just well Matt doesn't give a [ __ ] so
but if it's someone like a Dane Cook I
don't want a date and I don't know him
as well
we give him the wrong idea yeah then I
don't mmm
you know I mean yeah that makes sense
but I've come across so many I mean
pretty much every every comic I know
who's like moderately successful is on
there I've come across so many oh yeah
on all the apps oh I come across him on
all the apps really yeah
but you and I matched but we didn't
really talk on there then I just text
you
yeah I did that's the move right I feel
I think I'm gonna cancel my Raya it's $8
a month
oh is it I think I paid six if you pay
for the full year okay discount so I'm
stuck I can't cancel next year oh maybe
I should have paid for a year it's such
a waste I never go on day I haven't gone
on I mean how long we've been using it
I've been using for better but uh I
don't know six months yeah and you gone
on three days it's not worth it it's not
and you get you get what like 15 15
people a day or something and then you
run it on matches maybe for girls is
different but for you for us no it's the
same and then you you swipe through like
15 people and then it goes like we want
to keep this community yeah yeah yeah
that's right
yeah we're committed to fostering a
small community I'm like really are you
write every Instagram model I know is on
here yeah I I feel like the downfall for
me is I'm not famous enough to be like
all right I'm just famous enough to get
on so I'm not famous enough to be the
cool guy in Rio but if I'm on bumble
unlike the cool guy on bumble you know I
mean yeah but then do girls on bumble
know do you have photos on your dating
profiles of like you on set or like you
you know your IMDB page
No maybe like me wearing a suit on a red
carpet like a step-and-repeat or
something okay which is I just happen to
look okay in that picture you know I
mean like it's not I get it yeah I get
that
well I feel like that it's funny when I
swipe through guys and I'm sure it's
different for me because I work as quote
talent but I if I come across anyone
that looks like an actor I don't like if
they have a headshot or anything I don't
swipe on them on purpose interesting but
I can't date actors because they're too
good at acting true you know I can't
tell when they're being real and when
they're just trying to get my pants but
it aren't most guys kind of good enough
at that you know I mean I mean I guess
and I'm also pretty dumb like what do
you I am like it's not dumb I'm very no
matter how many times it happens to me
that I am a hopeless romantic and when a
guy seems like he's really into me and
says the right things like I was dating
a guy who was like we hadn't hooked up
yet okay and I told him I go look I
really I want to [ __ ] you but the thing
is I like you and so if i hook up with
you it's gonna mean something to me I'm
gonna have feelings about it it's not
just gonna be like a casual hookup and I
just don't know if it's a good idea cuz
I don't know if that's what you're
looking for you know and he was like you
know you deserve someone who gets you
and really wants to be with you and
respect you and he's like I respect that
and I don't want to do anything
oh wow that's gonna come between us and
then in the middle of the sentence you
start sucking him up yeah I was like oh
my god yeah okay nevermind forget
everything I was [ __ ] yes I [ __ ] him
and then it turned out it was all
[ __ ] he's wonderful
yes all right guys good ah [ __ ] that
guy's good that's a point is that I I'm
stupid cuz that'll happen over and over
and over and in the moment I always
believe the woods
I want to believe the actions but I
don't I believe the words so you're also
saying that for somebody you really
really like you hold off longer [ __ ]
them right yeah for somebody just kind
of like whatever you know you actually
you know think about having sex with
them just because you think maybe he's
attractive myself yes like the less I
like you the easier it is for me to have
sex with you I'm so broken I think no I
think that's most girls that makes sense
yeah how do I become less likeable well
here's the thing if you are I hate to
say this but the thing is women what we
want is this like it's not about people
are like Kate you owe it what like
people think I always want to hook up
with like quote famous guys or athletes
or whatever that's not what it's about
women want what's hard to get just like
men and for us it's like I dated a guy
who on the first date told me he's not a
girlfriend guy she's like I don't do
girlfriends I'm not a relationship guy
just like to date and have fun and if
you're not cool with that you know we
press shouldn't hang out and I was like
no I'm totally cool with that but in the
back of my mind I was like oh I want to
be the one to like turns him turn him
and then you know what happened I was
after like we dated for like a month he
was like you know what I can't believe
I'm saying this but like I don't really
think I would like it if you date other
people I only want to date you
and the entire time we're together I'm
positive he was cheating on me but in my
mind I was like oh my god I but I got
the one like I changed him like I made
him into a girlfriend guy and so I tried
so hard to hang on to that guy even
though I think that was even a line ID
right I'm saying move yeah
man these guys got some moves man I'm
giving you all the moon I want to be
like I'm gay I don't know I'm [ __ ]
chicks tear yeah and outside but I only
[ __ ] fat chicks dude yeah you're hot I'm
not gonna [ __ ] you do you do anything
like that like do you have any game I
die
I would think I do but I my mind doesn't
let me do it like how my like I'm I'm
not letting myself talk to the extras
yeah you're not I just don't think I
want to be a scumbag yep but I can't I
have my governor is too good it's just
like I want to be like the girl like my
friend Jen is such a [ __ ] to guys and
they all love her and she's like Kate if
you just that's what I was saying like
the guys that are famous
I really do treat them like like that
the famous actor guy I called him out on
his [ __ ] immediately that's why I never
saw him again like I call famous guys
out on their [ __ ] because I feel
like just you think just could you're
famous you can act like this so I call
them out I don't call out regular guys
like that because I'm I'm I'm just nice
I'm too nice I need to start being a
[ __ ] and you start being like that it's
not being a [ __ ] but like I wish I
could be the girl to that just [ __ ]
whoever I want like if I meet a hot guy
and I want to [ __ ] him just [ __ ] him but
I can't cuz in my back of my mind I'm
like but it's supposed to mean something
and like I should make him wait and
there's all these stupid rules in my
head yeah well I mean is it also
biological do you actually catch you
actually catch filling after that it's
not just the rules necessarily it's
actually some chemical reaction right
yeah I mean that's what they say you
know for me I catch feelings when I
cuddle it's not that sex it's the
cuddling that's why I don't caress
yeah I don't cuddle guys I don't like
weird there's a guy here's the other
thing if a guy doesn't pay for me I'll
never catch feelings it's crazy
wait what okay let's say we go out on
the date let's say we go out yeah as
friends me and you we are friends let's
say we go out for a drink tonight okay
and you don't pay I pay for myself you
pay for yourself huh then we end up
hooking up just because we're drunk and
we end up hooking up vodka in my mind
we're not dating because you didn't pay
for me so I won't catch feelings it's
really crazy as long as I keep it
platonic that way so every time we hang
out I pay for myself somehow you're
still in the friendzone even if I [ __ ]
you right so it's a mental thing yeah
not really a biological thing for it's
mental wow I didn't know that because
when a guy pays for you you can't help
but kind of feel like Oh
he's like kind of taking care of me and
I shouldn't pay for [ __ ] is what you're
saying I mean I'm not saying if there's
a girl you like and you want a date you
should pay for her cuz it's a major
turn-on when a guy pays for you on off
on it's a turn-on it's a good turn-on
even if it's something cheap or even if
it's something small like I once had a
guy buy me a gift at a Walgreens like we
just stopped to get like we just stopped
to get a gum or something and he bought
me on them so you call condoms gift yeah
2016 Jesus Christ you read my mind
um no he bought me a pillow bad a pillow
bed a pillow pet Oh pillow pet about
yeah pillow pet otherwise not
necessarily from Walgreens no but it
would happen to be out of Walgreens and
he was just like that's cute you should
have that and he brought it for me and I
just it instantly made me like really
into him instantly it was like oh that's
so sweet but into him for the long haul
I wanted to date em right right right
yeah right so if I'm saying if you if
you're out with a girl that you want to
bang but you don't want her to think you
guys are ever gonna have a future yeah
don't pay for her right see I'm I'm not
good at that I'm good at like the girl
I'm good with nice girls yeah I mean
like but like girls I want a date like
whatever like but like but like just
chicks that I want to bang horrible at
that well are you trying to have her
what are you trying to do
ah-ha
I won't even single uh program my last
girlfriend like maybe four months ago
so not that long not that long look man
I I would like to find somebody that I'm
super into doubt you know date for the
long term yeah but I gotta make sure I'm
like actually super intern that's a
problem with this last girl she was
super nice super cool I can see myself
even having some kind of future with her
but she's just I'm just not that into
her yep
you know what I mean yeah like I feel
like if it's the same same personality
same way worked but I was super into
that person it would have worked out you
know I mean do you mean you are like
super into her like was the sex not
quite there
chemistry thing or there was just
something it was everything I think she
she was just like a good companion good
friend but never like that spark that
passions necessarily you know I mean so
um I don't know like like the the
hooking up you know when on the road
even when you're in LA on the apps and
stuff after a while like as you're doing
it it's cool it's like ha man last night
you know I had sex with two girls like
this hot that hot whatever right yeah
it's fun for those moments but for the
times in between you're just laying in
your bed hungover you know sleeping by
yourself and watching it's kinda you
know it's empty especially does this
time of year make you cuz I wonder if
guys feel girls during around the
holiday season when the weather starts
to get cold i text i xed it a guy that i
haven't hooked up with in two years and
was like what's up what do you have to
we should get to get like i start going
back through every guy just cuz i'm like
there's something about this time of
year that makes me nostalgic maybe a
little lonely right it gets darker
earlier yeah it gets colder you don't
leave the house as much that's it two
guys two guys feel that way I mean we
just want to [ __ ] all this doesn't
matter the season yeah
we're not very seasonal right so you
don't have like the winter ones into
babies maybe I think that the getting
dark definitely affect me it does yeah I
mean that affects everyone right my
seasonal depression and things like I'm
not saying I'm depressed but you know
seasonal depression is the thing it is
yeah yeah I mean it's although it's 90
degrees out here today in LA so remember
I mean regardless I don't ever leave the
house so I get it
yeah well uh have you had any like awful
awful dates that was just like the worst
I've been fairly lucky I think not awful
um like that girl I told you about that
was about as bad as it got most of the
awful dates is kind of brought upon by
myself yeah by sometimes you know it's
like I just like really want to get laid
and I end up going on a bunch of dates
with girls down like yeah I'm sure but
then I it's it's like I in back of my
mind I'm
I'm still trying to tree him like really
nicely just cuz that's who I am like I
can't you're such a nice guy and like be
an [ __ ] yeah I mean yeah I could if I
really hate the girl but you know she's
done nothing wrong so eh whatever
that's your type I want to hook you up
with someone you're such a good guy um I
like like kind of artistic kind of more
like artistically talented people yeah
yeah yeah and creative
yeah creative and I'm definitely like a
more cute than hot type of person okay
yeah all right
you got you got somebody I'm just cute
any cichlid white black Asian Mexican
for white grouse or Asian and white mix
is Nexus good it is it good Mexican
anybody like that okay I'm thinking I'm
dominant I'm not my weakness mixed girls
age a particularly Asian and white Asian
white black girls have a thing for me
but I like black girls I have no problem
but it's not necessarily my preference
there's this whole thing it's called a
BW am black women for Asian men shut up
swear to [ __ ] god google it like
there's like meetup groups and [ __ ] they
love Asian man it's like a thing may I
don't know why but it's a thing
interesting yeah I didn't know that yeah
I'm on soulswipe with that it's a black
dating out really what's your preference
you like you like black athlete dudes me
yeah oh I like okay I I like all kinds
guys I've dated black I've dated Asian
dated white I do like athletes but
that's just because I am athletic and I
like guys that I'm really track eyes
that are in shape but not too big like
you know super duper cut like steroid
ripped is gross so heads yeah yeah but
uh the only thing I'm not attracted to
is blonde guys I just they look too much
like my brother right that's how I am
I'm not too attracted to Asian girls
right unless they look really different
from same yeah we members I don't know
man I just I like guys that are funny I
really like guys that are funny and and
smart but not as smart as me like are
you a little too smart oh yeah thank you
yeah I need guys that I can manipulate
and control and if they're too smart I
can't
Sam really I'm just kidding
I like a guy to challenge me though I
like guys that call me out on my [ __ ]
yes a lot of guys don't I get a lot of a
lot of ass kissers your ex-boyfriend was
Asian right one - Wow I needed two
Asians but one I was a boyfriend yeah
yeah um with with uh with me dating
right Asian it's it's becoming a normal
thing now even in like Hollywood acting
or like anything dating Asian is still
kind of novelty to a lot of girls
especially the girls that grew up in
like the middle of America yeah they
weren't they haven't met any Asian
people or something like that really so
dating an Asian it's kind of like a step
for them you know I mean so for me so
for me like it's it's way easier to tell
if a girl will be into me or not if she
has either previously data Asians she's
in the Asian stuff like anime or
something like that or she listens like
kpop I'm like [ __ ] her that night I
swear to god it's a thing it's it's they
gotta bring like be like predisposed to
Asians then it's just like shooting fish
that's it dude I I like my Asian
boyfriend the one I dated for a year was
hot was he he was Chinese Chinese
Chinese a hundred percent although it's
funny because people always thought he
was mixed like he he looked like he
could have a little white somewhere in
there but uh super hot tall ripped he
was like model
he's like a hot asian model guy yeah he
was really hot the other one not so not
as hot but SuperDuper funny I mean he
wasn't you don't have that honest I mean
I know I'm not the hottest guy kay you
know amazing in the sack and huge dick
Jimmy oh yeah huge [ __ ] at funny asian
[ __ ] huge honey and unfunny bubble
cocktail
funny asian dude - tacky
oh my god let me ask you this would you
ever date a stripper
mm I worked at a strip club what three
months that's what as a DJ you are not a
and San Diego really seedy strip club I
never banged any of the girls there cuz
you did it it was it was I don't want to
say the place no but it's like really
like shady like biker gang like the
[ __ ] door man his name was monster he
was an Aryan Brotherhood like [ __ ] like
that oh my god really gangster [ __ ] man
I didn't bang any strippers out first of
all is too scared and second of all is
like a really load gray strip club it's
not like a cheetah's with like 100 hot
ass wait no it's just like gross people
working it I can't believe you were the
door guy was in the Aryan Nation were
you afraid no they loved me because the
owner [ __ ] loved me treating me like
a son like when it because that was the
job I quit to come back up to LA to do
stand-up and all that cuz I saw how dark
of a road that was Wow
and then the owner will call me every
now and then he'll be like a Jimmy
everything all right in LA I'm like yeah
everything's cool he's like you need
anything I'm like no I'm okay he's like
okay should just check in and then he
hangs up shot I think yeah super
gangster is that the shittiest job you
ever had nuts it's fun I think you know
I wouldn't it was fine
I had fun yeah I was like 22 I mean
you're working at a strip club right uh
shittiest job I didn't like like a
finance internship I had like those
square jobs like at least this was kind
of gangster and go home brag to my
friends about it yeah and I'm sure and I
was just hanging out with it's
interesting people
although prison oh really really you
know people I use trying to say you got
a stripper friend oh I was just curious
I might uh hmm maybe I won I mean I'll
be smart enough to not like fall in love
and like be like a long-term but I'll go
bang a stripper oh well yeah I mean
really you would what a giver you're so
charitable Jimmy alright I'm a nice guy
have a bang a stripper that's a little I
mean I'll casually date a stripper with
that does that make sense but I long I
can't take it stripper back to my
parents you so how can you casually date
more than one girl at a time I I don't
usually but you could well I know
you could I was curious if you could if
I could oh if I mean mentally I could
yeah yeah I really don't care about him
yet interesting yeah um I date a Hooters
girl you did something yeah when was
that uh when I used to work at Hooters
you worked at Hooters I ran a comedy
club on a second floor hooters
wait yeah the one in Hollywood yeah oh
that's right I was started by me and
some friends I didn't know you worked at
the Hooters I was running the club like
I was there every night that was before
whoever took over now it was like every
night thing it was pretty good it was
okay I went there too I think I went up
there twice and there was always people
it was just kind of a crapshoot because
like it's like free tickets for people
on the street and then Hooters girls
don't want to be waitresses you know at
a comedy club no well yeah and the
lighting was not good oh yeah a lot of
issues but we had fun yeah they're a
good time was a good time
damn voila what anything else you want
to plug before I get you at you by the
way you're such an amazing guest and I
want to hook you up I want to set you up
on a date with someone I may be a couple
people because you're a really sweet guy
and I just feel like wait what about a
white girl I might have someone yeah I'm
down
III I'm gonna work this out I'm gonna
set you up on a date with someone of
them gonna make you come back and into
yes Jimmy what else you want to plug
anything else you wanna plug I was
coming up yeah I think oh yeah I'm at
the I'm headlining the Hollywood improv
on the 19th of November so that's coming
on so come by do that go to Jimmy comedy
calm that's my website you can find
tickets all the social media stuff on
there and funny Asian dude it's my
Twitter Instagram and yeah
you're amazing thank you so much for
being here guys Jimmy O yang make sure
you follow him follow me at Kate Q funny
and of course follow all things comedy
and we'll see you next time on Dave
fails bye thanks but